Nos dicen "Kim tenía curiosidad de saber si
el triángulo ∆ABC y el triángulo ∆GFE eran
congruentes, entonces intentó mapear una figura
en la otra usando una rotación", así que veamos,
este es el triángulo ABC y lo primero que
hizo fue rotar el triángulo ABC alrededor del
punto C para llegar hasta aquí. Eso es lo que se
representa en este diagrama. Y después nos dicen:
"Kim concluyó: no es posible mapear el
triángulo ∆ABC en el triángulo ∆GFE al
realizar una serie de transformaciones rígidas,
por lo tanto los triángulos no son congruentes".
Lo que quiero que hagas es que pauses el
video y pienses en la siguiente pregunta:
¿está Kim en lo correcto al decir que los
triángulos no son congruentes ya que no se
puede mapear el triángulo ABC en el triángulo
GFE usando transformaciones rígidas? Bien,
la forma en la que yo lo veo es la siguiente:
ella fue capaz de hacer la rotación para llegar
hasta acá, es decir, hizo una rotación alrededor
del punto C, por lo tanto, este es el punto B',
este es A' y C se mapea en sí mismo, por
lo que C = C'. Pero Kim aún no ha acabado,
todavía puede hacer una transformación rígida
adicional, una reflexión sobre la recta FG.
Si refleja sobre la recta FG, entonces este
punto se va a mapear en el punto E, justo así,
y después de hacer la reflexión podemos
darnos cuenta de que sí existe una serie
de transformaciones rígidas que mapean el
triángulo ABC en el triángulo GFE, por lo tanto,
Kim no está en lo correcto, ya que olvidó realizar
una última transformación rígida: la reflexión.